speaking of Elizabeth Warren yesterday I
told you that Elizabeth Warren had taken
a one-point lead in the New Hampshire
primary over Biden and a two-point lead
in New Hampshire over Bernie now since
then we have had another New Hampshire
poll which shows Bernie ahead and we
also have a new National Economist poll
which has Elizabeth Warren tied with Joe
Biden nationally 26 to 26 this is not a
single state okay this is national
polling other than a single Monmouth
poll in mid-august Joe Biden has led
every poll nationally dating all the way
back to before he even announced he was
running and we now have tonight a
Democratic primary debate where
Elizabeth Warren is at least in one poll
not trying to catch Joe Biden but Co
front-runner with Joe Biden at 26 26 so
let's look at this one poll and remember
it's just one poll but this is still
very very notable also notable is that
in this poll Bernie Sanders is all the
way down to 16% which I actually do find
difficult to believe so it's always
important to consider one poll no more
than that it is just one data point
unless there has been a significant real
shift away from Bernie towards Warren
it's difficult to imagine that both
Bernie and Warren are each ten points
ahead of Bernie but this is one poll so
now that we've seen this what you need
to do is nothing different what I mean
is it's the same situation as always you
need to stay engaged you need to go vote
when your state votes no matter what the
polls say but this is very interesting
in terms of the dynamics for tonight's
debate which for me has become a lot
more interesting in light of these
recent polling changes will the tone and
the feel of tonight's debate be
different because Warren is no longer at
least in this poll trying to come from
behind Biden and make her case but
rather a co front-runner if you were
Biden are you panicking
maybe not it's unclear how much Joe
Biden actually wants to be President but
pursuing that he really does want to be
President of the United States
if you are Joe Biden you have to be
worried about Elizabeth Warren's
momentum I got some emails yesterday in
light of this new poll saying hey David
Biden should step down I find this a
little bit silly rarely would anyone who
is leading even if it's tied for the
lead step aside
unless the argument about momentum is so
overwhelming and Biden really doesn't
want to be President of the United
States I don't see Biden stepping down
anytime soon but now there is a real
fight and the questions of speaking time
in tonight's debate will be immediate
questions we tend to see those who are
leading get disproportionately more
speaking time and while in one sense
that's completely unfair in another
sense it's completely expected once you
understand the corporate nature of these
debates on the major networks will
speaking time be impacted by the fact
that at least in this poll Elizabeth
Warren is a co front-runner with Joe
Biden we will have to see I hope you
will join me for a pre debate stream on
YouTube a half hour before the debate
starts and then live debate commentary
over on twitch at twitch TV slash David
Pakman if and this is a big big if if
nobody shuts us down all of that tonight
let me know what you think about this
new poll I want to tell you about one of
our sponsors called the Menlo Club
immense fashion community that provides
carefully curated style packages for any
type of guy and they're giving you as a
David Pakman show viewer your first box
for $35 off when you click the link
underneath this video or go to their
site and use the promo code Pakman as a
member of the Menlo Club you receive
delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style profile I hate shopping
for clothes it's always been a pain to
go to a store figure out what to buy and
that's why the Menlo Club is so perfect
for me all I had to do was fill out a
quiz on their website so they could
learn my sizes and style preferences and
then I received clothes that perfectly
fit my own personal style so far I've
really enjoyed what they've sent me all
of their clothing is designed by their
team in Los Angeles each
box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands 5 for everyday
wear New Republic Footwear and grande
see athleisure wear in every box they
send you you get a minimum of 2 items
often more every box is different
shipping is always free and they let you
exchange what you get if it doesn't fit
you can pause or cancel your
subscription at any time right now I am
on their monthly subscription for 60
bucks a month but they also offer a
seasonal subscription where they send
you a box of clothing every three months
for just 75 bucks but regardless of
which option you choose they're giving
everyone in our audience $35 off their
first box to redeem your $35 discount
just click the link under this video or
go to their website and use the promo
code Pakman at checkout